how great is it to have them here Max
and Amin and I wouldn't have mean to you
and the moment you had up there really
they really surprised me do they look
that little move they did you rehearse
that and everything huh yeah and we
haven't even got a chance to talk about
it yet so beautiful I just um
yeah I was super surprised I had no idea
that was gonna you also mentioned the
support you've gotten from Alex and how
many shows he's seen it how he's been
here what does that mean and is is it
time time for what you know what I'm
what I'm talking about it listen to have
a partner who's that supportive who
comes to that many shows you know we all
know what it's like to be in show
business it says it's a grind it's it's
being away a lot and he really makes the
effort so do I to kind of be there for
each other and it means a lot to me
mm-hm
how much were you miss I miss it
I might miss it a little bit because it
was just such a special moment it wasn't
just another show it was it was a great
show and it was a show where I didn't
even expect all that it was gonna be but
um I really did it I thought it was like
another gig that I was gonna do and it
was gonna be fine but actually turned
out to be something so incredibly
special and different and it's funny it
just taught me like when you approach
things that you go I'm gonna make this
the best show that Vegas ever seen it
when you're doing that in rehearsal from
the beginning you can actually make
mm-hmm you you made it you did make it
so it was it was awesome and we have a
great you had great crew and agree
and he's a very very special thing you
know I don't know you know whatever we
do next
of course I'm gonna try to make it
better but at the end of the day it'll
never be this this was something super
special do you ever look at your life
wonder how you got there if you made
different choices would you be happier
you don't recruit about second act in
the new and the new song second act
would be out you know around Christmas
so I'm super excited about that it's you
know I haven't done a type of made in
manhattan wedding planner type movie for
a long time and and i always get asked
about that what are you gonna do another
romantic we're gonna do and this is just
it's that type of feel good
inspirational movie and i can't i can't
wait for it to come out I mean we have
an amazing cast in Milo Vanessa Hudgens
Lea
it doesn't movie with me and we play
best friends and everything it was it
was really again a special project that
we did and and I did a song for it
called limitless which co-wrote so a
super like over-the-top about that I
mean I was like who do you think we
should get to do a song I was like SIA
of course and she did an amazing job and
it's a it's a great song mm-hmm you know
how I know it's so funny when I played
it for MMX it was a gonna be place and
tell me what you really think she was
like it sounds like a CEO song sounds
like here's a CEO song Jesus it's the
house Plagueis didn't you say that yeah
they know music they don't music and
they know you know me
[Music]